welcome to our new and Wolfram language
12 webinar series today is the third
session in a four part series that
covers significant areas of new and
expanded functionality in Mathematica
and the Wolfram language my name is
Jaime Petersen and I'm the technical
programs manager for Wolfram you a free
and open learning hub that features
interactive courses video classes and
webinars like this one
thank you for joining us today today's
topics cover the expanding calculus and
algebraic computation functionality in
the Wolfram language but today we'll be
showing you the latest in scientific
visualization for complex valued data
and functions Geographic data and
molecular structures joining us our
Devender Kapadia manager of our calculus
and algebra group adam strabinsky
symbolic algorithms developer bret
champion visualization manager and jason
biggs lead developer for chemistry
content okay I think we're ready to get
started with our presentations
Devendra and our calculus functionality
is our first topic up Devendra I'm ready
to pass things over to you Thank You
Jaime hello everyone and welcome to this
webinar this Devendra and it's my great
pleasure to speak to you about the
calculus features in version 12 now
calculus is probably the most popular
part of mathematic and Wolfram also for
students and in fact many people start
using Mathematica by using calculus by
integrating function or something of
that sort and then they go on to use it
forever baby so this this is a very very
popular area of Mathematica
but for version 12 we set is slightly
more ambitious set of goals so first of
all we said we would like to make our
functions more powerful and by adding
more algorithms and functions and things
we also wanted to come close to
applications like image processing and
other things the third point is that
very often people find our documentation
but they really cannot ask their own
questions very easily
so our question was can we make the
documentation absolutely world-class as
it already was but make it even even
better
and finally we said okay someone like
myself is a teacher
and it's not calculus for many years can
I actually give someone too you know a
full course in calculus and bring them
up to speed with how to use Wolfram
language for calculus so that's the set
of goals we had for ourselves and so to
keep those in mind when we talk were to
a seminar so the first one we said let's
implement new Alvin functions limits
there's integrals that can make them
more powerful we looked at integral
transforms which appear in image
processing for example the hunkered
transform and the radon transform we've
added more than 5,000 documentation
examples that's made the whole system
much more usable and then finally we
have gone a step further and actually
delivered a full scale Wolfram you
calculus course which has proved to be
very very popular so my goal today is to
try and give you a very brief overview
of all these very nice features of
version 12 and hope that you'll find
this version absolutely first-class to
use for calculus okay so let's begin
limits so here's a limit which has
basically been very difficult to do in
any real version so the limit is for a
function eat eat the polygon of polygons
of X over X now if you plot the function
it looks like it's going towards some
kind of a limit over here around 0.6 but
the question is how do you actually
compute this limit now when you compute
limits you probably won't use the
l'hopital's rule but in mathematical
prefer to use these expansions but then
for something like this
in 1996 the swiss mathematician dominic
grunts i working at the Swiss Federal
Institute of Technology actually gave a
much nicer idea and what group said is
there if you look at this expression
over here
switch off this polyamory inside and he
trying to expand the other earrings to
poly gamma you basically get something
like arrays 2x times X to negative 1/2
then you do another expansion plug back
to poly gamma the X cancels out and lo
and behold we get back this very nice
limit for the function so the groom's
algorithm is a very important feature of
version 12 and we have a Vulcan
fermentation of this not just was for
elementary functions but also for
special functions okay so on to the fact
that limits seldom exist the fact is
that many limits will not exist so for
example here's a function which is
pretty much beyond any kind of limit
computation it's an oscillatory function
and if you look at it around the origin
you see that to the left of the origin
you actually have the function
approaching zero but to the right there
is wild oscillation and the question is
how do you show that this limit does not
exist well in earlier versions there is
a bit hard but now there are several
ways to do it so for example you could
show that the limit from the left is 0
the limit from right is indeterminate
so that says the limit does not exist or
you could show the lower limit this a
new feature is negative 1 and the upper
limit is 1 that's the oscillation over
here but whatever it is all this put
together tells you that the limit at 0
does not exist so that's the full
language of limits that's possible with
the new version ok now
we went a step further and said how
about multivariate limits no that's a
standard topic in advanced calculus we
have not actually had this happen before
we have you got all the functionality
underneath but we decide to go ahead now
and actually implement a multivariate
limit function in Mathematica and that's
a pretty difficult limit but we quickly
get the answer to be negative 1/2 you
can see over here the function does
oscillate around 0 but eventually settle
down to limit negative 1/2 so this is a
pretty important feature which will make
it useful for advanced calculus students
to use the limit function in their
classrooms okay now one last point over
here is that we actually have sequence
limits so let's see have the sequence
over here and this sequence so here is
clearly oscillating widely but as far as
the upper low limits are concerned
there's no difficulty at all you can
work them out quite nicely and you can
see over here that this upper limit
which is in terms of root object gets
caught very easily by the new discrete
limit function okay so I talked about
l'hopital's rule a little early on but
there's actually a discrete version of
the l'hopital's rule and that's
something called the stalls cesaro rule
so this rule says that if you have a
limit and both numerator denominator
approach infinity then you can take a
difference nor derivative and get back
the answer and we use this very simple
idea here to actually get back a very
nice and so for this rather complicated
emmitt basically the sauce scissor has
just repeat of the outer sum and then
you get back the answer for in just a
flash ok so that's this toss is that
rule and the other point of course is
that we have support for nth derivatives
in this new release so I think earlier
is you could find the first or second
derivative but the other looking
function over here and the nth
derivative is a browser messy expression
over here but as soon as you put N
via specific integer you could have been
a very very nice expression and around a
few years ago might have Barry the
famous physicist pondered that in fact
these high derivatives generate
oscillations so that's the oscillatory
behavior of these higher derivatives so
you can compute the nth derivative you
can specialize and you can study the
oscillations of these higher integrators
okay so but derivatives the question was
what can we do with them we got in
derivatives what do we do with them but
it turns out at around 1930 the famous
tradition emerald post in fact derived a
very nice formula for inverting Laplace
transforms that's a very very difficult
problem and he said you can use the nth
derivative like I've done over here the
cake did in this case and a limit
computation the discrete limit
competition perpetually get back the
Laplace transform the inverse Laplace
transforms for many functions so your
simple example you have one waste minus
one and it quickly gives back this very
nice and so for the Laplace transform
inverse of one over s minus one now you
might say oh that's a very difficult
competition but it turns out that you
can actually take very high order
derivatives and get a pretty good
numerical approximation for the nth
derivative without too much work so the
post method is actually a practical
method because you can actually use high
derivatives to work out the approximate
inverse Laplace transform so we have a
very nice set of new limit functionality
we have nice derivatives and the next
point of course is how would integrals
well integrate is of course means the
most powerful function in calculus the
most popular function in calculus so
question is what more could we do with
it well we asked these very exotic tenor
integrals in version 12
that's an algebraic integral get back a
nice answer like over here and that's a
friendly integral also gives back a nice
answer
in fact we tested against around 70,000
integrals found a thousand that didn't
work and then tried to make them better
and better but this is a significant
achievement for integrate because this
is already so powerful what more can I
do with it well we actually have taken
it to the next step over here okay so uh
a few months ago before watching 12
degrees a Michael trot of walked into my
office and said you know there Indra
we've been here for 30 years
and you know what you still don't know
how to generate an object constant
integration so I said okay Michael we do
it for you so now in version 12 you can
say generated parameters goes to see and
it gives you back this integration
constant in the result which everyone
loves
so much and the point of course is that
this answer here represents the family
of curves so as the C varies so does the
integral curve in the plane so the point
is we have a nice feature a
long-standing demand which has been
fulfilled in this new release but of
course things are not so simple so if
you do a triple integral like over here
then we might get back these functions
of Y and X in the answer so really
speaking this process earlier generates
constants by solving simple P DS we have
cracked a major problem not just for
single integrals but also for multiple
integrals now one point of course is
that people who use our calculus
functionality often applied people so we
said what can we do for them so we
looked at these so-called huncle
transform you see in version 11 we
introduced the melon transform the melon
transfer is pretty useful but a bit
mathematical so with the Adhan Chico is
working on this melon transform which I
told me you know the Avenida we can
actually implement these hunkler
transforms quite easily but the point is
what are huncle transforms well how
field transforms are basically radially
symmetric fourier transform integrals so
here's a radius symmetrical function
it's really symmetrical over here you
find a Fourier transform version 12
that's a nice plot of Fourier transform
and in fact it is a hunka transform
computation underneath so huncle
transforms let us do very nice Fourier
transform complications to
understand this lady kind of mathematics
associated phoria transforms okay so uh
I don't essentially ago in nineteen
seventeen actually the famous Austrian
math menu hundred on published the paper
in which he said my problem is his
problem was to try and compute the
values of function given the integral of
that function along straight lines in
the plane now that looked like a piece
of very abstract mathematics but as time
is rolled by in fact this has become a
key feature of medical technology so
when a patient goes for a CT scan let's
say that's a section of the patient's
body then the doctor put bunch of x-rays
across that section in different
directions and the question for the CT
scan machine is from that mass of
information how do you get back the
patient's actual image and of course the
doctor can then come in and decide that
it's some series like cancer or maybe
pulmonary fibrosis or whatever so that
mathematics over here is in fact now
available in calculus we have the radon
transform which computes the radon
transform in a particular direction to
plane so the P over here and the Phi
actually specified different straight
lines in the plane and from that you can
get back the inverse radon transform and
that's the original function over here
so this is quite an achievement see what
happened was that Mellon transforms gave
us hunkler transforms and then hunkler
transforms give us Fourier transforms
and then those plura transforms are used
to compute inverse Laurent transforms so
this has been really an a very nice
release for me because we've seen things
working step by step in a certain order
but now we have radon transforms which
are actually very very important in
modern medicine okay so all that's very
good but the question was can we make
our functionality much easier to use or
not and so for version 12 we actually
had around five interns who work
full-time with us to solve six thousand
problems from a standard
popular textbook and having done that we
then pick the best few hundred and put
them into the pages for limit D and
integrate so these days now I actually a
very nice way to learn calculus there
are complete introduction to those
functions and I hope they'll really help
everyone so we have put internal effort
into documentation we had tried to
actually do a good job on all this now
the next point was we have calculus but
calculus does not just limit B and
integrate we actually have 250
mathematical functions well we are not
in turn a set of interns who worked on
those two and 50 functions and produce
around 4,000 new examples for these new
pages so now you have a kind of
encyclopedia of specialty functions
built into your copy of version 12 if
you upgrade you simply get the best
possible collection of special function
examples in the world basically
so that's it kind of collage of all
those a word cloud of all those 20 50
functions so if we've tried our very
best to make the documentation as useful
as possible ok one last point or years
that I've taught for a long time so
around year ago of my manager Roger
Gunson said in the Devendra why don't
you develop a new calculus course I said
ok let me try and this course is all
thanks to me people over here Jamie and
Kathleen are people who really worked
hard to make this course possible so we
have a full scale introduction to
calculus available on the web and in
fact you can get a very nice certificate
by completing the course lots of people
are doing it on my instrument we get
around 8,000 people come to the website
every month this is a very nice way for
you to learn Tellis it's totally free
there's been no problem at all in
getting certificate and I think that
this is where we go from Iran will try
and develop more and more courses to
make our calculus functions even more
visible to the world
ok so that brings me to the end of this
presentation so I hope you'll agree that
the version 12 functions are much more
learning and applicable than what we had
early on and I'll just take a minute now
to show you the features page where you
can actually look at these examples in
much more detail it's a very nicely done
page
lots of the 420 didn't do it from my
team and I'm very proud to look at all
the examples again the limit examples
the discrete limit examples the D
examples integrals integral transforms
Wolfram you calculus I hope you find
some time to go through all this and
actually you know enjoy the catalyst
features in version 12 so really that's
all I have to say for this presentation
it's been a great pleasure to speak to
you and I of course will address but I
see lots of nice comments coming up I'm
gonna try to address them as soon as
possible but do try and look at the page
over here and get some feel for what's
chain in version 12 so thank you very
much I'll stop over here okay so let me
start my part of the talk I will talk
about computation I'll strike
computation in version 12 my name is
Erwin ski I'm symbolic a Lorentz
developer and here is the plan for Mary
talk first I will talk about equation or
inequality solving and exact
optimization in those two categories we
we have mainly extensions of scope and
improvements in the existing functions
then I'll talk about equation
manipulation and equation of logic
proofs these are entirely new
functionality in version 12 so let me
start with equation inequality solving
first we can now find the political
properties of solution sets of systems
of polynomial equations inequality so
for instance here scares inequality and
cylindrical decomposition is a function
that computes for us explicit solution
set of this inequality we have so it
always starts with bounds on the first
variable then bounds on the second
variable and this is an explicit
description of a solution set and we can
visualize the result this is the
algebraic semi algebraic set that this
inequality describes so now we can
compute the boundary of this solution
set
so we tells him you got the composition
to compute boundary and here we get a
discrete equation inequality description
of the boundary of the solution set that
here's the boundary it looks like and we
can see that the solution set has three
components from the plot and indeed we
can compute see you in recall the
composition of each of the components so
here is the first component here is the
second component and here is the third
component and here is a plot now thanks
to the functionality here in Dakar the
composition we can actually color the
components differently because we have
xB solution for each of them okay here
now another a different two equation
inequality solving function is the
ability to specify vector and matrix
inequalities so for instance here's
here's a problem specified in a vector
language we are looking for two
orthogonal vectors such that component
wise vector Y is between minus vector X
and plus vector X so for instance here
in visualization this is the red vector
is plus X blue vector is minus X and the
green vector has to be in the Box
defined by these two by red and blue
vector and normal vector X is 1 and here
we specify that we are looking for
vectors and we get the solution for the
vectors and here is the solution is
visualized we can also fully solve
system of vector inequalities you will
introduce we get the solution written in
terms of coordinates of the vectors and
here is the visualization of the
solution set ok here here are other
improvements in equation in s inequality
solving so we have added new algorithm
for solving large triangular polynomial
systems so here is a timing
Harrison it's on a logarithmic scale so
you can see that version 12 is five
point nine times faster four problems
with two variables we chose triangular
problems of degree seven with randomly
generated coefficients for four
variables it's fifty four times already
faster and four for higher number of
variables version 11 what was timing out
at one hour version 12 can compute here
for five variables in less than 100
seconds for six variables in less than
1000 seconds another class that we have
extension extended the functionality for
is they have found an equation with
irrational coefficients so now we can
specify a fountain equation and some of
the coefficients are irrational and we
can solve for positive integers this is
another thing that was added in version
12 we can now specify the mainly
positive integers positive reals
negative reals and so on
so and here's the solution set positive
integer solutions and here is slightly
more complicated equation in four
variables we also are looking for
integer solutions and it has only two
solutions another area where we have
extended the functionality is solving
inequalities involving transient all
funky functions especially functions
that are meromorphic so now we can we
can exactly find the roots and have
hands of inequalities involving
meromorphic functions there's the
solution and here's the system involving
symbolic derivative so this derivative
does not have a closed form solution
nevertheless we are able to find its
zeros exactly as those root objects so
here's with me
they know the representation of fruit
objects in version 12 now we give gets
such a blob with numerical approximation
instead of their large root object that
you represents so if we put our cursor
on the blob we can see the exact
representation of of the root object and
here we visualize the solution so here
are the roots of the derivative ie
minima and Maxima of the function now
optimisation of periodic functions
that'sthat's not a class of functions
for which the computation has been
improved so here we have a combination
of trigonometric functions you can see
that there the whole function is not
periodic since they are composed with
with some non periodic function
nevertheless we can we can find the
minimum and here it is it again uses the
root objects which would be quite large
here in the older root object
representation and here we visualize the
solution that's what the function looks
like and here is the minimum another
class so we can find maximum value of
combination of periodic function with
incommensurable periods so we have sine
of square root of 2 times X and cosine
of 3 times X so the ratio of the periods
is not a rational number and so we get
the maximum value which is never
attained but but this is the the global
maximum value of this function and
compute the value which takes a while
this computer okay so let let me then
talk to about the next example this is
computing so we are looking for a
minimum value of combination of periodic
functions with commensurable periods now
over the integers so so we can see that
this is the these are the values of the
function over the integers and this is
the mean value a let me just okay here
it this finished computing I will not
start this at the second example just
showed the answer here it is okay next
class of problems for which functionally
was extended in version 12 is
optimization for back over vectors and
matrices so here again is a minimization
problem specified in a vector language
here again vector inequalities dot
products norms and here you get the
vector solution and this is the
visualization of the solution this is
the the optimal solution with which is
orthogonal to the X with norm one and
between minus X and X here is how we
find we solve musician problems for
matrices so this design codes the sort
of finding finding maximal eigen value
of a matrix right from the definition of
eigen value and here we get the maximal
eigen value and the eigen vector and we
can compare it with with the computation
done by the eigen system function and
indeed the maximal eigen value is here
and here we maximize the determinant of
a positive semi definite 3x3 matrix so
this matrix inequality here is means
that we are looking for positive semi
definite 3x3 matrix and the trace of the
matrix is supposed to 1 and we are
maximizing the determinant and here's
the result
okay other improvements in exact
optimization we can optimize univariate
elementary function over the integers
for instance this function there is the
optimum or function involving arctangent
log now here is optimization problem
involving trans central functions with
two variables we maximize this function
over the whole r2 and here is the
maximum we can visualize it here is what
it looks like and now we can solve
another class of problems this problems
involving function composition so we can
have quite deeply composed function and
we can compute maximum of this function
here is here is the plot and the maximum
point okay now for completely new
functionality we have added
functionality for manipulation my
operating equations inequalities by hand
so this is something for the K to 12
school students for instance you can now
solve a system of linear equations by
hand as one is taught at school multiply
the second equation by 2 subtract the
result from the first equation now
divide sides by 5 and we get the
solution for y and to get the solution
for X we multiply the last equation by
-3 add the first equation and divide
both sides of the equation by 2 and we
get the solution for X and we can do the
same with inequalities so for instance
here we have an inequality we can
subtract B from both sides we can divide
both sides of the equalities by a now we
get
piecewise expression as a result because
the result depends on the sign of the
constant we are dividing by and we can
add equation to an inequality and we can
we can add two inequalities we you can
see that other sides will automatically
reorder reorder the second inequality to
be able to add it to the first one and
one more function from this class is
apply sites this this one is a purely
structural function so it just applies
the same function to both sides of of
equations and the doesn't really mean
that the equation we derived this way is
true that that's just structural
operation for instance we can here apply
sides to to equation inside curried
conditional expression or we can apply a
function to each inequality in piecewise
function and ok so now let me talk about
equational proofs we can we have
introduced functionality for
representing equational proofs for in
axiomatic theories so for instance let's
take an axiomatic theory of boolean
algebra from our collection of axiomatic
theories here are the axioms now we can
prove this statement from the axioms and
we get back a proof object so it's it's
a proof with 83 steps and we can now
look at
some information derive from from the
truth objects for instance here is a
graph of the proof that shows how each
statement in the proof was shown based
of other statements of the on the proof
or here is data set which displays are
the details of the proof steps and here
in the second example let me show proof
that so here we have axioms of the group
theory so we have axiom for the
right-hand side unit I and now we can
show that left unit is also the right
unit is also a left unit so here is the
proof takes 11 steps and here is a proof
not notebook so this this is something
that will show the proof in human
readable form so this is something that
we can we can read so we can solve the
exercise that tell where we are asked to
show that I write units also left unit
here's the proof in eleven steps and
further information is available here at
our web page such a bright computation
and we can see all the examples I have
shown and some more so thank you thank
you Adam I think we've had a lot of
really good questions coming in and I
think maybe Devendra wanted to take an
opportunity to respond to some of those
Thank You Jaime so yes so I presentation
Adams absolutely fantastic you know Adam
doesn't make mistakes we have a joke in
our group that Adam is absolutely
perfect and you're very lucky to have
had a chance to you know listen to him
today but my point were you
that you actually can do a lot with
version 12 Thank You Donna for your
comment about the the the version 12
presentation he really liked him thank
you for that thank you Bruce for every
positive comments about the seminar I
noticed that Ellie asked about where can
I find information with generate
parameters what does change
well I recall that had forgotten to an
example and I recall adding it
there should be an example on the
generate parameters dot HTML page for
you for integrate if not a do email us
will send more information but this
presentation says all just new trade
rate parameters goes to see and should
find your answer to your question then
there was another question about the
inverse Laplace transform which is a
fantastic solution that's something I'm
working on right now so while you think
of 12-point oh I'm thinking one year
from now and I'm thinking that the
inverse Laplace transform is a very very
important feature for the future so
Naresh Patil thank you very much for
that suggestion inverse Laplace
transform very much on our minds we will
work on it very soon so I think that the
radon transform seems to very
interesting for some people I agree that
it'd be good to have in higher
dimensions the limit syntax is what you
do by hand
probably but if you don't prefer that
you could just use ordinary notation
just type in discrete limit or limit and
that should work just fine so thank you
for all the questions it's been great to
have all of you over here but I'll give
Adam a few minutes to talk about his
questions what he received from people
and then we'll close up over but thank
you Adam for an excellent presentation
well thank you very much
so one questions I so here is a question
about the root object so so let me let
me talk about this more if I can okay so
here is here are some samples so so what
what does this little square root in
circle mean so that that's a
representation of an exact number of
root object so this is just numerical
approximation of the fur to the first
three digits but but here if we look at
it it's it's the root object that that
is has been known in Mathematica since
version three in version 11 it would be
printed as a throat the one that we are
showing here in the tooltip the new
representation in version 12 is is this
blob so this is something we can we can
copy it out from here you can take
numerical value of it for instance with
100 digits and the input form of this
object that we can could see in version
11 and earlier and this representation
in in version 12 is for for root objects
and for algebraic number objects first
up here is Brett champion our
visualization manager and Brett I think
we're ready to hand things over to you
Thank You Jamie so we're gonna start by
looking at complex visualization which
is entirely new in version 12 and then
following that we'll look at Geographic
visualization which we've been sort of
incrementing upon for the past couple of
years but we'll start with complex and
so you know looking at sort of Adam and
Devendra stalks there's a lot of
symbolic things that have gone on and as
a company we take a lot of pride in
dealing with equations and formulas in
sort of their most general form not just
over the reals not just the real valued
about you know parts of things but
thinking of things as and as you know
their general complex behaviors and so
occasionally we will get reports from
people about simplified didn't you know
simplify you know something down to the
way that I thought and frequently the
reason for that is that the
simplification that they had in mind
really only applies under certain
conditions
you know it's perhaps true for real
numbers but not for complexes or it's
only valid and part of the complex plane
and so on the symbolic side we've had
like really strong support for complex
valued operations and the visualization
side sort of hadn't followed that into
the same depth and we decided that we
wanted to remedy that and so for version
12 we started working in on complex
specific visualizations and making it
easier to work with complex numbers and
complex valued formulas and functions
and so in version 12 we implemented and
introduced five new visualization
functions complex Lisp lot REM plots
ABS arc plots and then complex plot and
complex plot 3d and all of these have
sort of obvious analogs in the 2d sorry
in the real valued realm but hopefully
allow us to do things a little bit
easier when things become complex valued
and so
the first and sort of simplest of these
functions is complex list plot this is
essentially a list plot but for complex
valued things and so this is good for
visualizing discrete complex numbers
that may arise in various forms
typically they're going to be roots of
you know of some sort whether it's you
know sort of an explicit you know sort
of results coming out of in solve or
something else and so you know coming up
through school we always learned that
you know a polynomial of degree n has n
roots if you introduce transcendental
functions then things get a lot more
interesting and you because of
periodicity you get frequently an
infinite number of roots and so here
we're looking at the values of Z for
which sine of cosine of Z is Z so
basically where sine is cosine inverse
and we're just looking inside a disk of
radius 10 and it turns out that there's
727 such points and then we can just
sort of easily throw that into a plot
I'm not going to show all 700 of them
but just to make clear what the input to
complex list plot is we'll take the
first 10 and so this is just a list of
complex numbers and then complex let's
plot does the obvious thing prior to
version 12 you could do the same thing
by using list plot and applying REM and
extract manually extracting the real and
imaginary parts and then plotting those
as XY pairs and this just streamlines it
makes it a little bit simpler so the
other thing that this does is that this
because complex numbers have sort of
this dual way that we think of them so
we think of them in terms of their in
terms of a Cartesian sense with real and
imaginary parts but then we also think
of them frequently as a polar
representation with radius and angle and
so because of that then we added the
ability to for complex lists plot to use
polar axes instead of just the Cartesian
axes that list plot would normally have
and so even though this is in some ways
a very simple function we were looking
for ways to sort of take advantage of
the fact that we know that we have
complex numbers coming in and thinking
of things in those in that sense and so
then the next couple of examples are you
like I said yeah these are roots again I
mean they don't necessarily
think of them necessarily as roots but
they are and so if we take say a 500 by
500 matrix whose entries are randomly
chosen from minus 1 to 1 then we get 500
eigenvalues as our roots of a polynomial
with real coefficients and it turns out
that those are sort of evenly
distributed in this disk because it's
real coefficients then on the polynomial
underlying the eigenvalue computation
all of the solutions are going to come
in conjugate pairs and so you sort of
see we have a symmetry across the x axis
here I suppose I should say against
across the real axis if we do it with
complex valued then we don't necessarily
have the conjugate pairs and you get
sort of this nice evenly distributed set
of points inside of a disk which is I
think a really cool sort of feature that
comes out of this so the next function I
want to look at is rienne plot I have
seen variants of this come up numerous
times where somebody plots the third
roots or X to the 1/3 FX from minus 3 to
3 and they only get half of a plot and
that's because X to the 1/3 is not cube
root in the sense that you were you know
you learned about as a kid and then so
I'll just mention that yeah we have that
as a built-in function for probably a
couple years now that this is cube root
we're sort of the you know
which has sort of the symmetry going
from positive to negative but this one
is using principle values and whatnot
and you don't have this anything on the
left-hand side for the negative values
of x and then so REM plot is sort of a
hybrid visualization REM plot and abs
Arg plot and that they are expecting the
function to be complex valued but we're
plotting over a real-valued domain and
and so it's quite frequently that you're
thinking of
so some parameter space that is real
valued but the functions that you're
using may be complex valued for part of
that domain and so if we do re-implant
of this function then you see we get two
curves out of this we get this solid
line which is the real part and we get
it a dashed line which continues along
the x-axis the positive x-axis here
which is the imaginary part and this has
sort of REM plot specific options for
controlling what the real and imaginary
styles are how to do some of the
labeling but so I can make it
so that's say the real part is read and
the imaginary part is solid blue not
dashed at all
and so then you can
see that there's nothing you know we
needed to plot there's nothing over here
because there's this imaginary component
that isn't representable absorbed plot
is very similar to REM the basic concept
is the same
but instead of showing that the result
using the real and imaginary parts we're
looking at the polar representation with
the absolute value and the argument and
what this one shows that sort of the REM
plot didn't it really shows sort of very
well is that for X to the 1/3 the
absolute value of the function is you
know the same for positive and negative
values of x that it maintained the
absolute value is symmetric across x
equals 0 and the other thing that this
sort of shows and this happens a lot you
know in this function I'm coming up with
examples where it doesn't happen is you
know takes a little bit of work is that
you'll see that each of these sections
is sort of its own color and then it's a
constant color and and so what that
means is the color here is encoding the
argument so red is corresponding to 0
and this yellowish is corresponding to
PI over 1/3 and so for positive values
then because the argument is 0 you know
that this is a real valued function on
this half but this is all real values in
this on this side the 1/3 means that
it's a constant angle that that's you
know going off at that those complex
numbers are sort of shooting out in a
ray from the origin in a fixed direction
of PI over 3
and so if we look at the other two roots
of the other two branches of the cube
root then I mean you see that the
absolute values behave exactly the same
as for the principal root and and really
all that's changing is what direction
the solutions are going in so here it
was zero and one third over here it's
two thirds and pi and then over here we
know PI and minus PI and then over here
we have minus one-third and minus two
thirds and and so like sort of looking
at these you can get sort of different
insights and different views into how a
complex valued function may behave over
a real valued domain but the real you
know fun function is complex plot this
is the one where you know we spend a lot
of time looking at you know pretty
pictures looking at pretty pictures is
yeah so what's the worst part of the
visualization job
we hate looking at pretty pictures just
hours upon hours but anyway so this is
complex plot and complex plot 3d are
looking at complex valued functions over
complex value of domains and then both
of them the color similar to absurd plot
is representing the argument and so and
let's turn the legends on here
and so as before we go from minus PI is
turquoise through zero red to turquoise
again at PI and in this case we also
have sort of a secondary gradient going
on which is sort of full saturation of
the colors at zero when the magnitude
when the absolute value is 0 and then it
lightens up and fades out as it
increases to infinity and so you can you
know you get a pretty picture and we'll
talk in just a little bit about how to
interpret this pretty picture because
it's sort of hard perhaps to read off
actual values from these colors but
first I want to you know as I was saying
earlier we get you know people who
comment that I expected such-and-such to
simplify and it didn't and one such
simplification is you know that log of Z
to a power is the power times log of Z
and it turns out that this identity that
we all learned when we were 13 years old
or there abouts is only true when Z is
popped and when the real part of Z is
positive and if we do complex plot of
both of these expressions over the same
range then you can see that that is in
fact the fact the case that these look
different they agree when the real part
is positive but when it's negative
there's significant difference between
those two expressions and so
sort of all these algebraic operations
that we learned when very younger don't
necessarily apply and so now let's look
at how to interpret some of these colors
and so let's see
so if we look at you're sort of going
increasing our values of the argument so
turquoise to purple to red to orange to
yellow I'm gonna focus on the red orange
elo so as we go through that if that is
going clock or sorry counter clockwise
around a point then that corresponds to
a zero if it's going counterclockwise
and you get multiple times around then
it's a multiple zero and if you have say
Z to the three halves where you know
conceptually going to be like a zero and
a half or something you would see that
it would actually go one and a half
times through this cycle and you'd have
sort of a sharp break instead of
finishing up the cyclic nature poles on
the other hand are I mean you can sort
of think of them as reciprocals of zeros
and they go the other way around so it's
red orange yellow going clockwise
multiple pole pulls the same thing and
then essential singularities you end up
with sort of this infinite cycling
through a point and so we have orange or
red orange yellow red orange yellow red
orange yellow and we go through the
essential singularity and then we come
back out still going red orange yellow
red orange yellow red orange yellow and
if you have you know sort of a
higher-order essential singularity then
these get sort of really funky looking
but
but once you start to identify these
patterns then it's very easy to do a
complex plot look at it and go here the
zeros here are the poles etc so here I'm
plotting log of gamma over a particular
region and so red orange yellow
counterclockwise now that's 0 that's 0
that's 0 I mean actually all of these
are 0 the zeros there's 8 of them 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 and then some branch cuts
where we have sort of sharp transitions
from one color to another and for the
curious here's in solve telling us what
the actual eight zeros are over the same
domain and so once you sort of get used
to what the patterns look like it's sort
of very easy to identify different types
of features without necessarily running
through a solver that for a complicated
function might take a while you know
compared to how long it takes to
generate the plot so the other function
that we added was complex plot 3d this
is very similar to complex plot except
we're using height for the magnitude
instead of necessarily shading it out to
a lighter color and so this is sort of
the recreation of the picture that we
had on the very first slide of this talk
which is a recreation of a famous image
of gamma by Janka and md in 1909 just
the publication date for the book this
came from I'm not sure when they
actually drew it
and I like to show this just because
it's sort of really impressive to me
what they were able to do manually by
hand in the early 1900s and I'm just you
know awed by this you know and imagining
how much an effort this took compared to
typing something in and waiting a
fraction of a second and and so that
finishes up my talk about complex
visualization I'm going to move straight
on to Geographic visualization and then
following Jason's talk on molecular
visualization we'll start answering all
the visualization specific questions so
as I said in version 12 we are sort of
continuing to expand the set of
visualization functions for Geographic
data and so I'm going to sort of very
quickly go through how we might
represent Geographic data and so sort of
the most
are through entities such as this entity
for Chicago I recall that we have a few
I think was about 15% people knew the
language and so within the notebook
front end I get this by saying control
equal and I type Chicago and it helps
somewhat if I type it correctly and
let's try that again because um and and
so and that's a natural language
processing type of thing there's some
flexibility in how I type Chicago might
do a little bit of spell correction you
know it's not entirely requiring me to
be case sensitive or whatever and then
based on an entity I can say what's the
population and and so for things like
countries and cities and common well
known entities or you know areas this is
frequently a good way to represent or
work with geographic data the other way
is through sort of the low-level
representation which is geo position and
that family of objects and so this
corresponds roughly to the city of
Champaign Illinois where I am right now
so we're roughly at 40 degrees north and
88 degrees west and so we have geo
position which is sort of the built-in
encoding of that in the language I can
go from an entity to a geo position in a
couple ways I can ask for a position
property of that entity and get with a
little bit more well I guess that's
Chicago not champagnes and the numbers
aren't quite the same geo position will
also work on entities and extract the
same information and ultimately under
the hood all the visualization functions
are
going to be working with geo position or
a variant of that and its lowest level
and
when you have a lot of geographic data
it's usually best if you can make use of
sort of the multiform to deal with a lot
of the positions at once so here I'm
using a new 12 function to get random
geo positions so 100 points inside the
state of Illinois and
gyah position and this one looks a
little bit different from these and the
reasons that this is just a single point
and so it doesn't I mean we haven't done
anything terribly fancy with it in this
case there's a hundred of them and so we
have a summary box that tells us that
there's a hundred what the range is
gives us a little plot of what the
distribution is if you squint at this it
sort of looks like the shape of Illinois
and so having that data is sort of a
very useful thing and so in version
twelve we introduced four new
geovisualization functions and I'm going
to go through them in sort of order of
complexity of the data that they take so
the first is geo smooth histogram which
just takes a bunch of geo positions so
here I have about 4,000 locations in the
contiguous US each one representing a
brewery so this was a data set that's
Michael trots generated in a blog post a
few years ago and so well first just
take a couple a glance at a couple of
the previous ways that we had of
visualizing this and and so we had geo
list plot which just draws one point for
each of those locations and you can sort
of see where they are but everything
sort of you know especially in the
Northeast here sort of bunches together
and it's hard to see more detail on
what's going on other than there's a lot
of breweries here so so then we had a
geo histogram which is a discrete
binning by a default using hexagons of
the points and so we can see that
there's 133 in Chicago 73 near
Minneapolis and and so on and so forth
and we can sort of see where there's
or breweries and where there's less
Denver etc and so with version 12 we had
a geo smooth histogram which is sort of
the analogy analogous to smooth density
histogram for non geo data which uses
kernel density estimation to generate a
smooth gradient of values and so in this
case then we can sort of see the
northeast and Chicago and Detroit and
and see you sort of where the general
trends are and since its kernel density
estimation we have a kernel and we have
bandwidth and you have the ability to
affect both of those and use them to
vary the data a bit and so if we use a
smaller bandwidth then we get sort of
less spread out smooth than this and
sort of sharper bits of color this is
sort of much closer to our discrete
version here and if we use a larger one
then it spreads out more and you get
more diffuse a more diffuse sense of the
distribution and the other thing that we
handed for some of the geo functions and
we'll beef I think flowing this back in
to more of the core sizes functions in
the future is making it easy to say via
region function that I want the plot
restricted to the US and so in this case
it's generating the density as before
and then clipping it to the you know the
boundary of the US and so you don't get
things that bleed off into the ocean
where say that Harvard obviously aren't
any breweries in this dataset
and so that's so very useful and very
efficient way of doing that so the next
function is G a bubble chart so this
takes a bunch of locations and some sort
of scalar value and plots bubbles on the
map for each of those locations with the
bubble size scaled according to the
values and and so we see here we have
the 25 largest countries in the world by
population and we're showing them we're
representing that by the bubble size and
so we see that China and India are sort
of large and then the US and then things
get sort of smaller from there in the
case of something like a country where
it's sort of a large region not just the
single points but we need a single point
to place the bubble then it's put it
sort of a center for that location and
so we have a bubble sort of centered in
China and centered on India center of
the US etc and because you know this is
yeah so so obviously this builds on the
existing bubble chart of that we've had
since version 7 and and so it can sort
of take use of all of the functionality
of the charting functions so we can add
labels we can do themes to sort of
greatly change what the appearance looks
like so using a relief map for the
background instead of sort of a more
political type map
and so then the last ones that I want to
look at is Gina vector and Geo vector
platen she has stream plot and so this
uses a new sort of representation called
Geo vector which associates
so it's a vector with a bunch of geo
positions or geo locations and so in
this case this is a multi geo position
and then each of them has an Associated
magnitude and direction and there's you
know some variance on Geo vector on
whether you're using a pool or Cartesian
form of the vector the CHEO position can
be a list of entities etc it's very
flexible it can be generated by wind
vector data natively this calculation
takes a little bit of time so I'm I have
it pretty evaluated and so this was the
other day sort of looking at what the
wind is over France so here we have G a
stream plot first and it's interpreting
all of these as a field and sort of
sampling that field and creating sort of
stream lines that follow the winds
direction and this is sort of a more
continuous type of visualization that
geo vector plot is more discrete where
you have just a set of individual
vectors showing what the directions are
and similar to bubble charts now these
have direct analogs and vector plot and
this vector plot and this stream plot
and so we can change the vector marker
shape believe this was this option was
added in version 11.3 to change what our
vectors look like and just like with Geo
smooth histogram we can restrict the
stream plot to the outline of you know
to the borders of France and see what it
looks like over just that region so that
finishes what I wanted to say about
Geographic visualization I'll leave a
little bit of time for Jason to talk
about molecular visualization and
thank you very much
let's see hi-yah
thanks for thanks for that talk Brett so
I'm gonna talk today about molecular
visualization I the Wolfram language in
version 12 introduced a large number of
functions for for working with with
molecules so we're trying to make a more
of a jump into the world of
computational chemistry and so this is
this is a step in that direction let's
see I'm gonna talk let's so no hundred
twenty-five percent here so what I'm
gonna talk about mainly first creating
molecules the different ways that that
you can create the a molecule from a be
it from an entity or a name or smile
string or some or a list of atoms and
bonds show you how you can compute
properties and descriptor values and
then focus on the the main topic the
visualization how you can make 2d plots
with molecule plot and 3d plots you can
annotate those structures and with
molecule plot 3d it generates
coordinates on the fly based only on
connectivity and then using force fields
to clean it up show how you can do
substructure matching to find functional
groups inside a molecule or to take a
list of molecules and find a particular
substructure in that and then a time
permitting I have a couple of really
neat interactive examples showing how
you can given a list of functional
groups you could create an interactive
plot showing them and also a symmetry so
that one's really neat I might fly to
the end of it if we're running short on
time so so far in the end the Wolfram
language we've had chemical data
starting in version six chemical data
features over 40,000 entities molecules
drawn from drawn from data sources like
NIST and
Khem & Aldrich IU pack and so that all
of that stuff those entities are
available in chemical data if we ask
chemical data open close you get the the
list of all these entities right and so
behind each of these yellow boxes there
are our properties and you can ask for
the structure diagram or the melting
point and these are all what we like to
call curated properties these have been
brought into the knowledge base from
some external source these are
experimentally derived melting points
and and so so that is in the knowledge
base but starting so this takes you a
certain distance but then once you get
past these 40,000 molecules you need to
move on and we've got plans to increase
the size of this to a million two
million but even that is just a drop in
the bucket compared to the the size of
the chemical space and so right so in
order to to get properties for any
molecule you could think of you would
need to be able to create them on the
fly and query them for properties and so
that's why we we introduced the molecule
let's see so there this slide just shows
the various ways that you can create a
molecule so you can start with defining
a list of atoms and bonds so this was
has an oxygen a carbon it has an another
oxygen atom with a negative one charge
and then another one and then it has a
bond between the first two atoms a bond
between the second and third double and
these two are both singles so we
evaluate this and we get back our
molecule it displays in our in a
notebook as a summary box with some some
information this is the the in cheeki
it's a okay it's like a it's like a
molecule hash so if you take the in
cheeki they're meant to be you can
google that and if you find
this there should only be one molecule
that that that generates this in Chiqui
and so you can find information about
the the carbonate if you google that
right and so then once you create it you
can plot it in 2d or 3d and in both
cases we're generating these coordinates
coordinates on the fly not making a
knowledge-based call right and so then
we can use the the knowledge base to get
the properties so we have so here we
have propane this is a yellow box an
entity that represents propane and if if
you call entity value on it and ask for
all these different properties you get
this amount of information and that's
precisely what molecule does when it
when it when you give it this propane
entity it converts it into a molecule
and let's see I take a time to just
point out that molecule plot can work
with entities just fine it will under
the hood convert it to a molecule make
the plot and then return it so if I
evaluate this yeah so we get this this
stick figure for propane you can test
equivalence of molecules so you can
create a molecule from the entity or a
molecule just from the name propane and
they come back and they say are they are
the the same molecule some some of our
entities represent polymers or non
formulaic chemicals so those don't
translate into molecules and you get it
a message there are a few different
shorthands for creating a molecule so so
you can use any chemical name we use the
absent parser for parsing this for
turning this chemical name directly into
a molecule without without calling a
lookup table to see what this is when
you evaluate it it recognizes that you
start out with aniseed or nitrile right
here it's got a phenol at group at
position two and it's got a cyclohexyl
also a position to and it's entities
then tells you about the
three-dimensional arrangement of it
right so and we demonstrate in the
notebook and so this happens very
quickly
you're gonna evaluate all of these and
I'm I'm continually amazed by how good
that this this is at parsing chemical
names and I threw this one in just
because I I'm like I said I'm impressed
by this stuff and then so so this is -
SN 1s 2 carbon carbamoyl 1 and then I'm
gonna stop at that point but this in
this I you pack name it describes the
stereochemistry at various points it
describes the substituents and
everything here is everything required
to to generate this this molecule is in
that chemical name and so now we move on
to a somewhat less readable but easier
for a computer to understand is a smile
string and so in a smile string you can
represent a molecule it's like a
shorthand it's so this is an oxygen
double bonded to a carbon single bond
into another carbon carbon carbon and
then then there's one last carbon that's
that's off the chain and hydrogen atoms
are omitted if need be or they can be
added and so this is this is a you can
oftentimes find these smile strings on
the web or in various data sets and then
in Wolfram language version 12 you can
easily convert those into molecules so
then when you want to plot the molecule
have already shown how you can you can
take them create a molecule and feed it
to molecule plot their various plot
themes for molecule plot the number of
plot themes is going to increase in
future versions but right now you can
use plot themes to control whether
hydrogen's are shown
by default we some hydrogen's are shown
those that are not on a carbon so they
here by default we show these hydrogens
attached to the oxygen but you can say
omit all hydrogen's show all hydrogen's
show the plotted in black and white you
can add a legend quite easily to show
the what the different colors represent
red is for oxygen blue nitrogen you can
change those color rules easily if you
like you can make night all nitrogen's
and green and all oxygens in this nice
little green color as well and yeah you
can control whether hydrogen's are shown
and then we've got molecule plot 3b
again we create a sample molecule and we
plot it in 3d and so right then when I
clicked enter it generated 3d
coordinates using a distance geometry
method and then clean them up using the
MMFF force field and so this is a
reasonably good structure obviously to
get a better better geometry you'd have
to feed this to some hard truth post
hartree-fock method for geometry
optimization we have plot themes for
plot for the 3d as well I'm particularly
fond of the the tubes where it emits the
the normal spheres and the ball and
stick model again we've got legends
and color rules a lot of the same
options is for molecule plot and then so
next we have we introduce molecule
pattern which is a way to describe sub
structures within a molecule so you
could a molecule pattern you could have
just the string o represents an atom an
oxygen atom or you could have atom any
atom with a formal charge greater than
zero is this pattern or any atom that is
a member of ring
we can attach those to those patterns to
labels and so we end up with this
association now when we feed this to
molecule plot it'll automatically
generate the legend and show you that
these are the ring atoms these are the
cations and these are the oxygen atoms
in yellow the same thing works for bonds
you can create a pond a pattern for a
nitrogen nitrogen bond you can create a
pattern for a halide halite bond for
anything any bond featuring chlorine
fluorine bromine or iodine or you could
create a pattern for a polar bond where
the two atoms in the bond are have
opposite partial charges so in this in
this the partial one atom has a Parcells
charge greater than 0.2 one atom has a
partial charge less than minus point two
and when we when we feed this to a
molecule plot we can see that it
highlights the nitrogen nitrogen bonds
the polar bond and the halogen bonds
finally then you can create a more a
bigger pattern that with than just two
atoms in one bond you can you use
molecule pattern for that and it's got
the same argument structure as molecule
list of atoms list of bonds and then it
works in the same way so this shows
where the carbonic ester functional
group is located in this particular
molecule you can do substructure
filtering this is fairly neat so so here
I've got an icon I can eyes list of 3000
smile strings we create the molecule by
entering that notice that was rather
quick and then we create a pattern for
ether for a die errol ether this is an
aromatic carbon atom bonded to an oxygen
bonded to another aromatic carbon atom
so we've got moles you'll see is a list
of 3000 molecules see so this is what
the ether pattern represents
now you take that list of molecules put
it to select and say molecule contains
cue ether pattern and right away it
comes back and says that there were 40
molecules in that with the ether and so
then you can highlight all of those in a
grid of plots and I am really running
out of time here yeah so that took a
second to produce but here it shows all
the different cases where you have the
dye aryl ether and yeah so then I will
flip and just show these fairly briefly
this is a an I can eyes list of a
functional groups taken from this web
source on the web you can create an
interactive plot here where you could
say highlight charged highlight aromatic
atoms like nitro dialkyl ethers alright
and then finally here we go you can
create let me just show what the the
code looks like behind this so this is a
relatively simple code here and so you
evaluate this and it'll automatically
create this molecule create the 3d
coordinates and then figure out the
point group was tetrahedral and then
show you and then you can show all of
the like the c3 axes
you'll see there's one C 3 axis along
each carbon nitrogen bond and you've got
all the you can show all the different
planes of symmetry yep and I am
definitely out of time so
okay so I'm going to try to tackle a
couple of the questions that have come
up
starting with sort of the complex
visualization and so one of the
questions that are actually a few of the
questions that come up are with regard
to the use of color in the complex
visualizations and you sort of if we've
chosen defaults for the complex viz and
you know a bizarre plot and complex plot
and complex plot 3d are all using the
same sequence of colors that goes from
turquoise to turquoise sort of in a
cycle but but this is configurable and
so I mean first I'll just comment
because is that this this color sequin
isn't quite just hue it's been adjusted
a little bit so that we don't have quite
so much variation and brightness
otherwise sort of the turquoise would be
cyan and be super bright and same with
yellow and so we've sort of balanced it
out so that things are sort of evenly
weighted a bit in this color system in
this color scheme that said you know as
with you know pretty much all
visualization functions you can change
what scheme you want to use so if you
want a non cyclic color function then by
all means set it to something that isn't
cyclic such as rainbow or you know I
think if I did it's a grayscale
great tones then you get sort of
non-cyclic and that shows off some of
the branch cuts a little bit better
where it jumps from PI to minus PI in
particular gray tones might be better
for purposes where you're doing black
and white reproduction or you know you
want to be especially have people with
not full color discernment and so that's
a possibility the other thing that I
didn't really cover in my talk for time
considerations is that there's a lot of
variations on our lightness scheme and
so here I'm going to set it to a cyclic
log ABS and so then in this case in
addition to the color changing with the
argument we're actually also varying the
lightness and darkness on a sort of
powers of two basis according to the
absolute value or the magnitude and
these are reasonably well documented on
the dock in the documentation for
complex plot but there's a lot of
flexibility in complex plots in complex
plot 3d for changing what the coloring
is used
it supports plot theme which banks which
is lots of things and then basically all
of these functions support all the
normal options for label style and and
legends and whatnot
so I think that
most of what the people were asking
about for the complex is for the
geographic viz then we're aware that you
know sometimes the default maps are a
little bit blurry and that is high on
our list to improve and so Andy if you
play with geo background you can there's
some vector forms there in terms of like
country borders and whatnot
and then also you know if you want you
can point to your own you know to a
different geoserver a different source
of background Maps using the geoserver
option and then the other questions for
the geo stuff I think was mostly little
things but I want to hit them you know
as quickly as I can
so the brewery's data this is a dataset
that I processed elsewhere and copied
into this notebook to save time in space
when I get a chance I'll try to put a
link to Michael's blog post where he
derived this you know for geo position
so these are latitude and longitude it
is possible for these to contain
altitude as well for the
we don't include it in a lot of things
by default but it is possible to
represent it there and I'm thinking
about actually making use of that for
some future geo vis functions I mean and
actually this couldn't even be
time-stamped although I'm not going to
try to input that by hand at the moment
although it does arise occasionally
especially if you get like position
information for satellites then you get
sort of geo positions with high
elevation and very specific time stamp
on where the space station was at a
particular instant and so the region
function special vacation that we used
I'm not going to try it right now it
should work with arbitrary polygons it
might be a little bit slower but that
really shouldn't be it maybe though
that's you know it's a little bit of
work to get it in just the right form
and because you need to make sure that
you have a polygon of a Geo position and
that the coordinates are specified on
the earth for it to sort of clip out the
correct region and so I think that
covers most of the immediate questions
that I saw and so now I'll turn it over
to Jason if he has any questions that he
would like to answer so thank you
so there was a question about like
ignition points and whatnot and so we do
have some data we won't have that data
for everything but the way I got here
was I just typed in control equals
butane ignition point and so it comes
back as showing me that we have a
property called a chemical property
called auto ignition point and for
butane it is populated probably four
maybe four other molecules it might not
be populated ah so so yeah but so that
depends on access to curated data
someone asked about tri methyl sterile
ammonium and so we're able to parse that
chemical name directly to a structure
and we can generate a 3d plot from it so
this guy is going to be a big floppy
molecule so the the percentage of the
time that it spends in this particular
configuration I don't have enough
information to to say but it's a
reasonable structure someone asked about
reactions we're definitely interested in
adding a chemical reactions in future
version for now we have a molecule
modified which can change a molecule so
in this case I create n hexane just a
straight chain of six carbon atoms with
hydrogen's and I add a bond between the
first and the sixth carbon and it will
create cyclohexane you can then take
that cyclohexane and add a bond from any
any of them to an oxygen an external
oxygen and so you can create a
cyclohexanone you could also set a
formal charge a lot of these are spelled
out more in depth in the the new in
version 12 marketing page for all of
this stuff someone asked about movies so
it would be it would be great to be able
to make connection to MD simulations
either running them directly in the
Wolfram language or just connecting to a
program that's made to do that the PDB
database so right now importing a ppb
into a molecule is not hooked up I was
able before version 12 came out I'd get
mole files XYZ SDF files mole too but a
PDP is is at the top of the list for new
formats and we're also definitely
interested in a crystal crystal and non
molecular chemicals so solid-state it
would need some some new head then they
wouldn't just be molecules I think some
hunk of of germanium or so or something
so it's gonna have a lot of different
things inside at the lattice the the
coordinates the different properties or
whatnot and so so that's something we're
interested in doing but we don't have a
proper design for that any what I'd like
to say is if there's any stuff that that
you want for chemistry send us send us
feedback in some way or another and that
can help to guide where we go in the
future